und wir wollen diese neuesten
entwicklungen in der ukraine weiter
einordnen dafür begrüße ich jetzt die
verteidigungsexperten claudia major bei
mir leiterin der forschungsgruppe
sicherheitspolitik bei der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik guten morgen
frau major morgen wir haben das gerade
gehört die offensive im don was hat
begonnen was bedeutet das jetzt
das bedeutet dass die offensive auf dem
die letzten wochen gewartet haben jetzt
wirklich los gegangen ist hat es gibt
schwere artillerieangriffe auf denn
jetzt lohans kontrakt lief und wir
müssen uns darauf einstellen dass die
russischen kräfte sich jetzt wirklich
darauf konzentrieren werden dieses
gebiet zu kontrollieren und einzunehmen
sehr rücksichtslos um vorgeben wie wir
die letzten wochen auch schon gesehen
haben wie ist denn der zustand der
ukrainischen armee im moment haben sie
eine chance den don was zu verteidigen
die ukrainische armee davon profitiert
dass sie tatsächlich westliche
waffenlieferungen bekommen hat das heißt
sie ist jetzt besser aufgestellt aber
wahrscheinlich noch nicht genug um zwei
aufgaben zu machen nämlich einmal
wirklich diesem sehr starken angriff zu
widerstehen und im besten falle von
russland besetzte gebiete
zurückzuerobern da braucht sie noch mehr
unterstützung von den westlichen staaten
sie sprechen gerade die
waffenlieferungen des westens an und
fordert kiew da ja wirklich täglich die
lieferung schwerer waffen deutschland
stellt sich da bislang quer die
bundesregierung lehnt es ab wie ist es
zu bewerten
das ist sehr bedauerlich viele unserer
partner liefern bereits schwere waffen
und die tschechische republik hat
beispielsweise panzer von alter sowjet
art geliefert die slowakei auch die usa
großbritannien liefern schwere waffen
und es geht wirklich darum die ukraine
zu befähigen zu widerstehen und ihr
territorium zurück zu erobern wir haben
gesehen beispielsweise in butter was
unter russischer besetzung passiert das
und kriegsverbrechen begangen worden wir
sehen den russischen angriff in mariupol
wie die stadt komplett zerstört wurde
das heißt es liegt auch an unserer
unterstützung mit durch schwere waffen
ob die ukraine diesen angriff
zurückschlagen kann und im besten fall
noch gebiet zurückerobern kann schwere
waffen also panzer artillerie und
kampfflugzeuge jetzt hat deutschland ja
indirekt hilfe durch finanzhilfen
zugesagt
reicht das für das land die finanzhilfen
die er zugesagt worden sind sind im
prinzip gut und richtig sie lösen aber
das kurzfristige problem nicht denn es
geht jetzt
in dieser offensive und in den
anstehenden kämpfen die ukraine besser
aufzustellen das heißt finanzen sind gut
aber jetzt in dieser akuten phase
braucht es wirklich die schweren waffen
die sie angesprochen haben artillerie
gepanzerte fahrzeuge und ähnliches und
wie kann die ukraine schnellstmöglich an
diese waffen kommen wir haben gesehen
dass in den usa eine entscheidung
teilweise nur zwei tage dauert von der
entscheidung des präsidenten bis zur
lieferung das heißt die staaten liefern
schon und das kommt auch in der ukraine
an das haben wir bei dem beispiel
tschechische republik und slowakei
gesehen das liegt also am politischen
willen sagen sie es liegt am politischen
willen und dann auch dem was noch an
militärischen fähigkeiten also noch
vorhanden ist es sind die marder die in
deutschland diskutiert worden sind oder
alte leopard-panzer aber es liegt
erstmal an der politischen entscheidung
wollen wir das wirklich und wollen wir
das schnell jetzt haben wir auch
raketenangriffe im rest des landes
gesehen gestern am ostermontag
was erwarten wir von putin welche
langfristigen ziele verfolgt er in der
ukraine
momentan konzentriert sich russland auf
die regionen don was aber wenn man sich
die äußerung von regierungsvertretern
ansieht und auch sonstige äußerungen
kann man sehen dass russland von ihrem
ursprünglichen ziel die ukraine zu
kontrollieren nicht abgewichen ist es
gibt angriff in andere teile der ukraine
es gibt immer noch
hinweise auf die sogenannte
entnazifizierung also den eliten wechsel
in der ukraine und russland spricht der
ukraine immer noch die eigene identität
und staatlichkeit ab möchte sie also als
eigenständigen staat de facto auslöschen
und deswegen ist das eine momentane
konzentration auf den don was aber
sobald russland in der lage ist wieder
darüber hinaus zu gehen müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass die angriffe sich wieder
ausbreiten ich habe mir noch kurz auf
mario pohl von russen umzingelt ist die
stadt aber noch nicht eingenommen wie
wichtig ist die stadt aus militärisch
strategischer sicht würdige für russland
sie ist für russland sehr wichtig war
dass die große hartmann stadt am
asowschen meer ist und auch ein
wichtiger punkt in der landtag darüber
zugriff
und weil sie momentan noch sehr viele
kräfte bindet das heißt wenn russland
tatsächlich mario pohl einnehmen würde
würden dadurch auch wieder truppen
freigesetzt die anders eingesetzt werden
können es wäre aber über das militär
strategischen heimlich großer
symbolischer sie war jubel hat seit
beginn des krieges wieder standen und
das hat natürlich auch eine symbolische
bedeutung für die ukraine dass sie es
wieder standen dass sie es geschafft
haben einer so großen russischen
übermacht so lange zu widerstehen roma
gehören diese erwartete großoffensive
der russischen armee in der ost ukraine
soll begonnen haben wenn das wirklich so
ist was bedeutet das dann wir haben
jetzt ukrainische berichte dass das
atelier angriffe auf in der region der
nets glanz und kraft gegeben hat und das
heißt dass wir uns auf einen sehr harten
sehr brutalen angriff einstellen müssen
aufgrund der massierung der russischen
truppen und auch der angekündigten
russischen intention wirklich diese
gebiete kontrollieren zu wollen also
wahrscheinlich noch eine sehr brutale
vater führung heißt wahrscheinlich das
zusammenziehen der der truppen und
stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
stark die ukrainische armee ist und was
die ukraine der russischen armee
entgegensetzen können da und dort im
osten was wir gesehen haben den letzten
wochen ist dass waffenlieferungen
unterschied machen dass die ukrainische
armee so gut widerstanden hat bis jetzt
liegt auch daran dass die westlichen
staaten sie unterstützt haben und damit
kommen wir zu dem thema schwere
waffenlieferungen es geht jetzt für die
ukraine darum dass sie diesen angriff
widerstehen kann dass sie ihn abwehren
kann und dass sie im besten falle die
von denen die von russland seit dem 24
februar besetzten ukrainischen gebiete
zurückerobern kann und das wird ihr nur
gelingen wenn sie wirklich von den
westlichen staaten massiv auch mit
schweren waffen unterstützt wird
bundeskanzler scholz hat ja mal gesagt
all das was sinnvoll ist und schnell
wird das wird geliefert das heißt es
müssten schwere waffen auch aus
deutschland geliefert werden können sie
uns mal müssen alle keine militär und
waffenexperten oder expertin wo ist denn
jetzt der unterschied vor allen dingen
auch zwischen leichten und schweren
waffen also leichten waffen sind
vereinfacht gesagt so was wie
maschinengewehre und schwere waffen sind
wirklich die waffen die man bei so einer
großen offensive braucht das ist
artillerie es sind gepanzerte fahrzeuge
das sind panzer das ist flugabwehr und
diese schweren sachen liefern
nato-partner die usa sogar kleinere
staaten wie tschechische republik oder
die slowakei die liefern so was
wir machen das bislang nicht jetzt gibt
es verschiedene wege entweder
deutschland liefert selbst diese
schweren waffen oder es gibt auch diese
ringen tausche dass man sagt die
slowakei liefert flugabwehr und dafür
helfen wir der slowakei ihre eigene
flugabwehr trotzdem noch aufrecht zu
erhalten also es gibt verschiedene
mittel und wege und wir als deutsche
müssen uns überlegen wollen wir das oder
wollen wir es nicht und bisher hat sich
die bundesregierung er überlegt zu
zahlen also von einer milliarde euro ist
jetzt in einer neuen runde die rede
bringt das war's also hilft das der
ukraine oder würden sie sagen eigentlich
helfen nur schwere war also leichter
waffen hat deutschland schon geliefert
dieses diese geldzusagen sind gut und
die sind richtig sie wirken aber erst
langfristig weil das muss gezahlt werden
und die ukraine muss dafür sich ihre
entsprechend sachen kaufen was wir aber
jetzt brauchen ist in diesem dieser
akuten offensive unterstützung das heißt
man kann das eine gegen das andere nicht
aus spielen ja es braucht die
langfristige finanzielle unterstützung
das ist gut aber es braucht zusätzlich
in der akuten phase
waffen unterstützung und da sind wir als
eines der größten und stärksten länder
in europa auch gefragt wenn es gerade
gehört und das ist im prinzip die
meldung dieses morgens die großoffensive
im osten des landes die russische groß
offensive hat offenbar begonnen was
bedeutet das jetzt konkret für die
ukraine für die ukraine heißt dass wir
noch mal in eine sehr brutale phase des
krieges eintreten es gibt die angriffe
in der region der nets klo hans und auch
aktiv aber auch noch in anderen bereich
das gab auch noch angriffe auf wwf im
westen kiew und auch der kampf um mario
pohl geht weiter aber es scheint jetzt
diese große offensive zu sein auf die
sich russland in den letzten wochen
vorbereitet hat und die mit sehr starken
und sehr brutalen angriffen auf die
zivilbevölkerung einhergehen wird hier
wird ja aktuell sehr viel darüber
debattiert also vor allen dingen hier
bei uns in deutschland wie es mit
lieferungen aus sieht also leichte
waffen werden geliefert aber die
forderung aus der ukraine heißt ja auch
schwere waffen sollen geliefert werden
auch aus deutschland mit geld und nicht
umgehen sondern direkt ist denn die
bundeswehr überhaupt in der lage
irgendetwas noch zu schicken oder gibt
es hersteller die im depot weil die zeit
drängt ja ganz offensichtlich dass da
jetzt was kommen könnte
verschiedene angebote auch von seiten
der industrie es gibt die angebote der
älteren marder schützenpanzer in die man
noch mal auf möbeln konnte es gibt die
angebote für ältere leopard-panzer die
bundeswehr kann auch in ihrer eigenen
reserven noch einmal reingucken ich
denke wenn der politische wille da ist
schweres gerät zu liefern dann gibt es
verschiedene möglichkeiten das zu machen
die spd-vorsitzende war gerade bei uns
und hat gesagt im prinzip ist bei der
bundeswehr nichts mehr zu holen aber hat
auf die industrie verwiesen es war nicht
so ganz klar inwieweit es dort noch
kapazitäten gibt oder nicht aber damit
sind wir natürlich sofort bei der frage
wie die ukrainische armee die sich ja
auch seit wochen im prinzip vorbereitet
hat genau wie die russen jetzt reagieren
kann mit den schweren waffen die sie
jetzt zum beispiel aus den usa bekommt
aus tschechien auch also wie ist die
ukrainische armee jetzt in diesem moment
für diese neue oder gegen diese neue
offensive russlands gerüstet ich denke
die wichtige information ist wirklich
dass die waffenlieferung der letzten
wochen eine unterschied gemacht haben
die wenigsten hätten erwartet dass die
ukraine so gut widerstehen kann wie sie
das gemacht hat und dann muss man ganz
klar sagen das waren auch die westlichen
waffenlieferungen wenn wir also jetzt
auf die nächsten wochen gucken dann ist
es in unserem auch im deutschen
sicherheitspolitischen interesse zu
sagen wir wollen die ukraine befähigen
dass sie widerstehen kann und dass sie
möglichst die von russland seit februar
besetzten gebiete zurückerobern kann und
dafür braucht sie diese schweren waffen
wie artillerie wie gepanzerte fahrzeuge
wie panzer wie flugabwehr sonst wird die
russische offensive gewinnen es ist ja
immer wieder die rede von eskalation
eine eskalation wäre es natürlich wenn
russland wirklich polen angreifen würde
jetzt haben wir gesehen dass in lewis
raketen eingeschlagen sind sehr nahe an
der grenze zu polen das kann ja auch mal
sein dass ich so eine rakete verirrt
glauben sie dass dann der nato bündnis
war schon ausgerufen wird oder nur wenn
es nur wenn es eine militärische ziele
sind die wirklich mit absicht getroffen
werden also nach nach artikel 5 das war
schon sein vertrag ist also des nato
vertrages ist ein angriff auf einen nato
staaten ein die andere nato staaten zu
hilfe dass so ein bisschen
lebensversicherungs klausel der artikel
5 wird ausgerufen wenn alle nato-staaten
sich darauf einigen man müsste in einem
solchen krisenfall gucken ist es eine
und endete also war es ein integrierter
angriff war das mit absicht an angriff
war dass möglicherweise eine
fehleinschätzung die nato hat sehr klar
gesagt dass sie das ihren schutz
verbrechen vor schutz versprechen
tschuldigung steht dass sie also alle
ihre mitglieder verteidigen wird das sie
aber nicht eskalieren möchte wenn es
also eine rakete war die möglicherweise
nicht mit absicht über die grenze gehen
sollte wird die nato versuchen diese
situation zu deeskalieren sie hat kein
interesse an der eskalation aber dass
schutz versprechen dass die nato staaten
geschützt werden und alle zu hilfe eilen
das ist da und dafür hat sich die nato
in den letzten wochen auf vorbereitet
mit truppenverstärkungen mit mehr
luftraumüberwachung mit mehr abwehr das
heißt das sind die beiden szenarien
immer denken muss der bündnisfall oder
wenn möglich der eskalation wir haben ja
in den letzten wochen immer schon und
mit anderen expertinnen und experten
über politische lösungen aber auch um
die frage der politischen ziele des
russischen präsidenten putin gesprochen
ich glaube man kann behaupten dass ein
ziel die ganze ukraine zu besetzten kiew
zu erobern gescheitert ist erscheint
sich jetzt auf den osten zu
konzentrieren vielleicht kommt es auch
dazu dass er gewisse gebiete dort
erobert und halten kann aber was kommt
danach also wie muss man sich das
vorstellen jetzt in den nächsten wochen
und monaten was könnte geschehen
viele sollte darauf hin dass die
konzentration auf den don was jetzt
gerade wirklich eine momentane anpassung
ist dass russland aber von dem
übergeordneten ziel die ukraine zu
kontrollieren und als eigenständigen
staat abzuschaffen dass ihr davon nicht
abgerückt sind das kann man den anderen
aussagen von russischen
regierungsvertretern sehen die immer
noch von den nazi fi zierung also
auswechseln der eliten sprechen und die
immer noch die staatlichkeit der ukraine
in frage stellen also immer noch sagen
das ist eigentlich kein eigener staat
wir müssen uns also darauf einstellen
dass das eine momentane anpassung ist
aber sobald russland wieder in der lage
ist auch militärisch weiter zu machen
sie weiter anderen werden und das könnte
bedeuten dass es noch lange dauert ja
und vor allem glaube ich was die
menschen jetzt in der ukraine vom gefühl
haben man es nirgends sicher also wenn
der westen jetzt auch angegriffen wird
aber das besprechen wir dann noch im
laufe der woche frau maja vielen
herzlichen dank für ihren besuch ihrer
einordnung und einschätzung sein könnten